[Music]
good evening welcome to Tucker crossing
tonight for about 10 minutes after her
general election defeat three years ago
Hillary Clinton appeared to retreat into
contemplative seclusion she wanted to
run the woods near her home in Chappaqua
New York looking a little lost
now some people made fun of her for
doing that but in fact it was a
promising start humiliation can be the
beginning of wisdom as those of us
who've been fired in public and tell you
but the period didn't last long
before long Hillary was back on the road
for years like the circus so many cities
so many excuses
the Russians us say WikiLeaks same thing
dumped the John Podesta emails I have my
complaints about former director Comey
the use of my email account was turned
into you know the biggest scandal since
lord knows when they covered it like it
was Pearl Harbor if you look at Facebook
the vast majority of the news news items
posted were fake there's all these
stories about you know guys over in
Macedonia who are running these fake
news sites I inherit nothing from the
Democratic Party I also think I was the
victim of a very broad assumption I was
gonna win you know if the election meant
on October 27th I'd be your president
and it wasn't it was on October 28th and
there was just a lot of funny business
going on around that the Russians
Facebook WikiLeaks Jim Comey the
macedonians the Democratic Party itself
Hillary Clinton blame them all this was
not someone coming to terms with a loss
it was someone refusing to admit one and
in fact over time that became Hillary's
de facto position on the whole thing
despite what you may have heard she
didn't really lose the 2016 election at
all she won it she's the real president
right now this is her reelection
campaign so as recently as a few months
ago even her fellow Democrats would have
laughed privately at that idea that
would have mocked it as delusional not
anymore
now something we're taking Hillary more
seriously than they have in a long time
an article in yesterday's New York Times
describes growing pan
among Democratic donors Joe Biden
suddenly looks weak and incapable much
of the rest of the field clearly is too
extreme to win a national election so
who's going to beat Donald Trump next
year some of the party are starting to
think it could be Hillary Clinton and
clearly this is the thought that is
crossed Hillary Clinton's mind in
private she's expressed her willingness
to enter the race as if to prove it her
personal website just added a policy
section that doesn't mean she's running
but suddenly it's clear that she very
well could run